Quentin Tarantino's film once upon a
time in Hollywood is packed with small
details and references to real-life
events but you don't need to be a Los
Angeles native or a true crime buff to
get all the knots will point out all the
small details and once upon a time that
you missed obviously if you haven't seen
the film yet here's your spoiler warning
if you caught a hint of deja vu during
the scenes in which Rick Dalton and
cliff Boothe are filming bounty law and
being interviewed about it it wasn't a
coincidence in the tradition of classic
western films and television shows
reusing the same set to save money the
set we're bounty law takes place mirrors
a town we saw in Django Unchained
specifically it's the place where bounty
hunter dr. Schultz first meets Django
while in pursuit of his own bounty the
only question remaining is whether a
character inspired by dr. Schultz ever
appeared in an episode of bounty law in
the Tarantino verse Timothy Olyphant
might be tired of acting as the fastest
gunslinger in the West but one of this
movie's small details makes it clear
that Tarantino isn't sick of seeing him
do it in 2004 all of its starred in
Deadwood as Seth Bullock a man whose
quick draw is one of the fastest around
after that he appeared in 2001's
justified a modern-day adaptation of
Elmore Leonard's fire in the hole' which
saw him playing the part of a dedicated
law man with a ludicrously fast draw in
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood's
depiction of the real-life TV Western
called Lancer Oliphant plays actor James
Stacey who on that show played Johnny
Madrid Lancer a man who's extremely
quick with a gun it's a nice way to some
of olifants past roles but it's also
just perfect casting there's a reason
audiences have been willing to accept
all events as a cowboy whether in modern
day or period pieces for nearly 20 years
it just works
what are you packing
you'll pay to find that out oh you gotta
ask cold water run through your veins
Zoe Bell has worked with Quentin
Tarantino for a long time their first
collaboration was during 2003 s Kill
Bill Vol 1 when Bell worked as Booma
Thurman stunt double from there Bell
continued to work with the director
doing stunts in Inglourious Basterds and
Death Proof soon she also started
performing in more visible roles
appearing as herself in death Proof
along with bit roles in Django Unchained
and the hateful eight in once upon a
time in Hollywood Bell got a promotion
to stunt coordinator giving her
responsibility for all the action that
audiences see on screen in a fittingly
metatextual small detail Bell appears in
the film as well playing Janet the wife
to Kurt Russell stunt coordinator Randy
Bell's actual job on set was making sure
that stunts were performed safely
without excess cost to the production so
it's perfect that her role as Janet
involves furiously interrupting cliff
and Bruce Lee's backstage brawl in the
world of once upon a time in Hollywood
Rick Dalton's had quite a career while
he missed out on nabbing Steve McQueen's
role in the Great Escape he might have
gotten the juicier role in fourteen
fists of McCluskey after all the latter
films seem to be inspired by the quote
real events of inglorious basterds in
the clip we see Rick plays a soldier who
blasts away at the Nazi High Command
with a flamethrower in an obvious parody
of Tarantino's World War two flick the
screen credit is more than just a wink
to one of Tarantino's other films it's
also an early hint that once upon a time
in Hollywood isn't going to be a basic
retelling of Sharon Tate's murder that
some feared it would be when the film
was first announced inglorious basterds
famously ends with Hitler burning to
death in a theater alongside most of the
Nazi High Command in a gleeful sku of
actual historical events by reminding
eagle-eyed viewers of that film's climax
early in his new film Tarantino is able
to foreshadow Sharon Tate surviving the
Manson Family in the tried-and-true
tradition of Ferris Bueller's Day Off
and nearly every superhero movie
released in the last 15 years once upon
a time in Hollywood actually has a
post-credits sequence Rick Dalton
filming a commercial for red apples
Rhett's noting that they're not only the
best around but have been the best since
the mid 1800s of course it's all
publicity for the camera since Ric
actually hates the brand but the
character would be alone in that opinion
in the Tarantino universe red apple
cigarettes have shown up in a bunch of
Tarantino's movies both Mia Wallace and
pumpkin smoke the brand in Pulp Fiction
the bride walks by a billboard
advertising them in Kill Bill and Bob
from the hate plate prefers the brand as
well bob enjoyed a Manzana Roja red
apple isn't the only Tarantino exclusive
brand that makes its way into the world
of Once Upon a Time in Hollywood Big
Kahuna burger the fast food franchise
that's most well known to most movie
goers as the last meal for poor Brad and
Pulp Fiction appears on a billboard
during one of the film's many driving
scenes maybe they should have had Jules
do an advertisement for them instead
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]